what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we are going to watch
today Gravity Falls
weirdmageddon part dos John how's it
going it's good how are you sir it's
good it's good sir sir good sir ladies
and gentlemen leave a like that's all we
ask of you today to leave that like and
also yeah we also do suggest that if you
want to do a full-length Reaction watch
along where you sync up with your own
copy of Gravity Falls that is available
for our super sexy Rejects at our
patreon page take you to all who have
joined there's a lot going on behind
YouTube Behind the Scenes that uh you
don't need to worry about but we do so
thank you to all I've been showing your
support over here patreon lastly the
team of prepper they probably settle
down these highlights let's get to it
foreign
[Music]
folks only way to Salvation is to
embrace the Triangular ways of our
Overlord any object with more than three
sides is full oh probably what Bill
wants I reckon I've been living a lot
everyone's dying anyways it's been fun
turning Gravity Falls inside out
rounding up all its terrified citizens
and then stacking them into this massive
Throne of Frozen human Agony oh God
there's an iron throne for you it's time
to take our chaos worldwide set the
world of flame with your weirdness ah
global domination I would get used to
heavens
this might be more complicated than I
thought I think I broke something what
[Laughter]
strange prison bubbles
awesome
you're choking me let my body be your
Shield
huh oh the entire Brown a bouncy castle
do you hear 80s music and does the air
smell like childlike Wonder
oh she doesn't want to leave this is
Mabel's prison yes definitely absolutely
[ __ ] everyone today's weather calls for
rainbows with a Chance of dance parties
this lines up really well please come to
the ice cream Beach your unicorn is
being towed what is this new world
shining shimmering splendid
Maple lands rainbows have colors only
bees and art students can see now who
wants to go on The Grand Tour do we have
a choice no go for it guys excellent and
the Only Rule there are no rules except
for one rule which is very serious
but no one would ever break it so it's
not worth mentioning
perfect listen creepy dream guys we're
not here to party okay we just need to
find Mabel and get her out of here our
homegirl Mabel lives at her next stop oh
yeah it's like Simpsons road Rage don't
forget this world was created by Bill
Ground Up Bones or babies or something
you don't know that we need to grab
Mabel and get the heck out of here oh
Mabel she's at the top of the tallest
tower guarded by those big buff waffle
guards there's no way
someone hand me some syrup
it's happening the moment we train for
oh don't worry man I gotcha oh my
goodness it's like Aqua Teen Hunger
Force hang in there Mabel
[Music]
industrial sprinkles I want it
[Music]
there's a cut of this but Dipper she
doesn't want to go
well I sort of woke up here it's it's
complicated what are you saying I'm
saying this is my home now and I don't
want to be saved
Endless Summer where we'll never have to
grow up sun shines all day the party
never ends and now that you guys are
here finally perfect Mabel we're not
here to party all of this is crazy
there's always time to party
that's why I prepared a backup Dipper
with a more supportive attitude whoa
the cool tip rad Dipper
fresh I like
my sister and punctuating every sentence
with a high five oh don't mind a fight
I'm sorry I can't leave him hanging
don't leave him hanging it's awkward
it's the rules this world always knows
what you want sometimes even before you
do
really I wanted a chinchilla right again
Mabel land who doesn't want to change
that doesn't mean you can just stay in
here forever hey take a chill pill those
grow on trees here
Maple man knows just what you want and
always provides
oh
yes putting Center nice
we've got a monster truck full of
fireworks fake IDs and pranking supplies
wanna drive this truck through the high
school and glue this plunger to the
principal's head yes yes I do why do you
need fake IDs at too Wendy fake IDs at
the no rules please don't worry dude
there's nothing in this world that could
break me from our mission
[Music]
uh no way it's a trap don't go with him
Zeus no matter what he offers sorry dude
even if it is all a dream I gotta play
just one game come on dad
that kind of makes sense
for once stop listening to your head and
listen to your heart Mabel land has
something for everyone and you
[Music]
oh none of us can escape the borders of
kind of force field keeping us in Who
would know how to fix it whoo I wonder
it would take a will of titanium not to
give in to its Temptation fetch me
Gideon and take the rest of the day off
things just got a little more
interesting oh what a smart trap animal
tree
[Music]
yes
are those animals stuck there
oh hey Wendy what's up thought you were
busy wrecking the school or whatever oh
my God he's gonna get her I think that
stuff you said about this place is right
really well now we just need a plan
don't worry you always think of
something
[Music]
you know you're so much smarter than
like everyone else here it is it's kind
of funny if you were older you'd be like
my dream guy
in this place it could finally be just
you and me come on man just take my hand
wait oh this isn't real
oh yes
you shouldn't have done that different
we're watching you
that's terrifying
animal tree
oh my gosh Burger bush under article
smiley face of exhibit squeaky duck you
are hereby accused of breaking our one
rule mentioning reality
a reality is what you make it
there's gotta be another way if Dipper
wishes to stay he must plead his case in
the ultimate trial of fantasy versus
reality
to freaking totally win that
always cut the commercial on a funny
holy yarn ball Batman oh eyes for the
honorable Judge kitty kitty meow meow
face schwarzstein
[Applause]
this trial begins right meow naha
if Dipper wins Mabel will return with
him to the real world if he loses he
will be banished forever replaced with
Town darling dippy fresh
[Music]
winning a trial is what it takes to get
you to come home with us then so be it
I'm sorry Dipper but I can only speak
through my legal team now you have a
doctorate degree in hunkiness yeah if
their sleeves ripped off let's hear
opening statements your honor Town spoke
lovely ladies of the jury
laughs
I'm gonna have the best photo ever and
how do you like my new picture have fun
[Music]
oh man I
I don't know
I've had that happen
shave off my head diabolical the Tipper
didn't get any
ah
heartbreak disaster broken promises
that's reality for you out there it's
nothing but hard who wants pug Sundays
made with real pugs
I haven't even presented my case do you
even have a case yes I do your honor I
call as a witness Mabel Pines
I might not have all the answers I'm not
stylish and I'm not cool and I can't
make pugs appear out of thin air
okay
[Applause]
[Laughter]
it was okay I'm not gonna lie but
there's a better way to get through it
than denial and that's with help from
people who care about you I don't want
to hear it Dipper
but I have a razor
you're crazy
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
I've always been there for each other
yeah
I'm not taking Ford's apprenticeship
we've traveled to heck and back to get
you and we're going back together leave
this fantasy world let's beat Bill and
grow up together
[Music]
awkward sibling hug
[Music]
this and it's all over
fear sibling hug oh don't do the patch
[Music]
oh man I never noticed how bright this
place is
out of there your rain over this land is
over all right that's the Sherlock duck
from the show
everyone get on yes
Waddles all right guys are you ready for
this
[Music]
you all good everyone good
hey Dipper I appreciate what you said
back there but if you want to take
Ford's apprenticeship I won't get in
your way okay
man I went nuts back there I mean come
on the real world can't be that bad
right
oh just you wait
[Music]
just
it oh man this is the first time I've
ever felt happy
is that the thing creating a force field
oh what's up gum I love stuck to the
couch
wait what was that
Stan
grab the crossbow yeah
yeah Dan kids
just so everyone knows we're out of
toilet paper hey welcome back
is this reality John Paul Sartre
postulated that every existing thing is
born without reason prolongs itself out
of weakness and dies by chance totally
righteous bro I know nicely done I love
reveals that the dumb characters are
actually really smart that's right man
philosophizers so Dipper's not in love
with Wendy he's in love with Mabel
this whole time that's right that is
kind of beautiful
[Music]
you're gonna get married I think what
they're doing weirdmageddon is awesome I
feel like they can even go darker I was
watching this going how come they're not
walking around seeing a bunch of people
crucified in the fog what happened to
all the Headless people with uh their
heads on spikes yeah there's a lot
further you can go with this but I feel
like once again Disney holding back
that's just my personal feelings on the
matter it's really really hypocritical
of them to speak upon reality and then
not show us the Grim realities of such a
situation as this yeah it's just not
realistic that the things that I'm
imagining would happen wouldn't happen
yeah where's the blood rain
you know yeah exactly things like that I
don't get it the fantasy land you see
the problem with the fantasy land that I
I feel like I would not like about it is
as much as I'm an individual who would
love to win the lottery take all the
money
hire someone to kill John and then film
myself reacting to learning the news
monetize that I've got a whole situation
mapped out here that could this is a
great way to capitalize off of this
situation uh but that's for another time
uh hopefully in the next five years so
beyond that what I think is with the
fantasy world the problem that occurs
with that is there's no sense of again I
would totally win the lottery uh but
with this world where everything is just
given to you upon a whim upon a quick
wish there's no chance of earning
anything so you I don't feel like you
would be able to truly appreciate you
take it for granted there's a sense and
sometimes the only way to really
appreciate
something is you got to experience the
other thing a lot of the time and if you
rob yourself entirely of that then you
won't be able to appreciate it so then
being stuck in the fantasy where
everything you get is
right it's at your fingertips at any
given moment
then I feel like you could actually wind
up feeling a little empty but if you can
get the right drugs to get you
distracted from that then who knows
maybe it's all right again I win the
lottery because that doesn't solve all
your problems it solves one major
problem
murdering John so what'd you think John
I was gonna say so so what you're saying
is that things aren't really worth it
without sacrifice and hardship to
contrast with the good things
yeah I don't like any of those things
but I know they're necessary
you simpled
anyway you have a sister you get along
with
but I'll kill her too
I don't need to kill her I guess not I
guess it's not really no that's true I'm
gonna need a reaction on camera as well
you can get my family yeah yeah yeah I
know I got all mapped out I don't think
I moved closer to you yeah yeah hey
Humphreys has come over here I'm gonna
shoot the reaction reaction to What Oh
no you're gonna love it don't worry
uh yeah no I agree I really like
weirdmageddon I really like the uh part
like you know ostensibly it will be all
the remaining parts of the season and
thus far each one has been distinct uh
while you know providing a nice uh you
know Act of this situation you know
especially after the turn last week the
Discover Mabel is being held in this
bubble Gideon makes his face turn and
then yeah we we delve in and uh I liked
it I mean you know you can see what the
lesson is eventually going to be that
yeah you need the dark to balance out
the light and you can't just you know uh
succumb when you're gonna start
balancing to a fantasy me yeah
when you start balancing out that
Darkness within you with some light
um
you know like a week or two shows up
here
give it a week or two being like I've
had it Greg
yeah let me preach his life advice
would you just say a rate okay yeah
[Laughter]
and don't comment below no yes I will
yell at you
insults loudly and with much Gusto yeah
yes
yeah that's me Negative Nancy over here
I could use a fantasy world I could use
a piece you only brought me one egg
salad sandwich yesterday
I have most of the other one I can go
home and get it
that's how you balance out this fantasy
world has plenty of egg salads
uh but yeah man like they do a really
nice job of balancing out especially in
these late episodes things that are like
kind of disturbing and and more adult
oriented but not going too far into you
know actually being disturbing so it's
got that thrill of like oh man I don't
know exactly what's gonna happen even if
yeah you can tell what the lessons might
be and uh I don't know I liked all the
different little set pieces and stuff
this is you know anytime you have a
place like this I think it's a good
excuse for people to you know throw you
know you have your character who the
place is based on so you have your like
stereotypical girl things but I think
it's a good excuse to just throw
imagination at the wall and see what
sticks we needed we should have got cool
Dipper
oh yeah Dipsy fresh or whatever his name
is yeah I don't know why we didn't get a
cool dip Daisy fresh they should have
swapped him out yeah and just made him
the protagonist of the rest of the
season
I would have been happy with that yeah
his sunglasses his his General attitude
just way better than the character we've
been journeying with all this time
and uh as much as it's a place without
rules needs some rules yeah I really
questioned the point of them like why
would they want to break into a school
with a fake ID like that's fulfilling a
really dark fantasy if you want to
torture the principal you know
yeah plus you don't need a fake ID to
get into school
I mean if why would you need the fake
guy yeah unless it's like a Specialties
probably yeah what do they need Facebook
you really got me caught up in this like
I don't understand the purpose of the
fake IDs
maybe in Mabel land they're all like
adult age so they need fake school IDs
to pretend like they're younger than
they are
well then I got two more episodes to go
and then it's all done and then Greg
writes his sequel that takes place 20
years from now Dipper married he has
settled down he did not marry Wendy who
is now in a very abusive relationship
good and Mabel she is a Pioneer she is
someone who's actually made a name for
herself she is a television personality
where Dipper he kind of like put
everything behind and he doesn't talk to
his sister anymore because he rejected
so much of his Ambitions because he had
to keep looking after her and then when
she got famous she wanted him to manage
his career she wanted him to manage her
career But ultimately
that's not the life Dipper wanted now
Dipper he tries to convince himself that
he's happy
where Mabel she tries to convince
herself that yeah she might be famous
and she gets to date some of the best
looking men in the world and often gets
to fool around with some of these pop
stars she gets to interview ultimately
she's not happy either and that's when
the rise of Bill Cipher returns again
and this time Bill he's not coming back
in yellow no he's a shade of dark red oh
and also uh it's played by none other
than Brendan Gleason your kids Brendan
Gleason is
Harry Potter franchise yeah uh yeah he's
taking a human form and now he's ready
to torture and go after uh the lineage
of what are their last names
the pines
and all that we're able to crap African
full blast yeah and then you can get
Richard Jenkins to play Stanford and you
can get uh you know Clint Eastwood to
play uh Grunkle Stan well I look I know
the key to improv is yes and I hate to
break it's a huge job but Grunkle Stan's
dead oh no well yeah I guess he's pretty
old he did not die and he also well he
took his own life oh no it's it's a real
like
adults versions that ends with Dipper
dying to save Mabel but does Mabel live
or is the closing shot of the movie
implying that she also liked
proving his sacrifice worthless and thus
it is a nihilistic Universe yeah open to
interpretation what happened it sounds
like so what about Susan Wendy are they
oh soos
diabetes and heart disease yes yeah
unable to get his weight under control
and then when his real dad actually does
come back it's only to pull the plug on
his life support machine Wendy goes to
jail for killing her husband rightfully
so and um her kids in the process died
in the fire good so good I really like
to write the Gravity Falls follow-up
because I feel like there's a more
realistic version of this that if we're
talking about maturing with reality
that's more than likely what's going to
happen with these guys it's a gravity
follow-up yeah what happens
when
Gravity Falls on our lives
you feel the gravity of life of the real
world yeah yeah it's deeper now hey
let's do a picture
David Gandy David look uh we're gonna
wrap up Gravity Falls before the end of
the month we have your your book book in
the journal number three number three
David that we were told not
not
to read because it has spoilers in here
yeah so we haven't looked at it an inch
I get what you're trying to do now
you're trying to sabotage our reactions
that something might pop up in here we'd
be like
well I read the books I already knew
that was gonna happen so thanks David
right now I just saw the ending thanks
David oh you really no I saw a platypus
that was very cool and cute go to the
last page all right
[Laughter]
last page oh my God an empty wall yeah I
know what that's like so David thank you
so much for
um
looking out for us don't worry the last
day of Gravity Falls I will be wearing
my dip hat oh that should have kept cool
dip a lot if we were in my dipper hat
John will be wearing The Fez
oh wait do I have The Fez or I have the
dipper hat I think they're both here
as they should be sure so that I can
wear whichever head I want alternate
it's hard to put that when you have
headphones I'll just wear the book on my
head sit very very still that's right uh
but thank you bud for for being here for
so long you are you are our Stanford
yeah real creep
thanks for being here too
foreign